el primero fue que from ya sabía lo que
iba a pasar y que pudo haberlo evitado
porque ya tiene información de estos
actos de violencia que van a ocurrir el
6 de enero el segundo argumento que
hicieron los demócratas es que trump
impulso incitó a sus simpatizantes a la
violencia a través de palabras que había
repetido en los meses anteriores al 6 de
enero y en sus trinos que constantemente
envió para provocar estos actos de
violencia el tercero porque trump actuó
deliberadamente porque como lo decía el
propio james rating él no envió ayuda
cuando esto ocurrió no hizo nada y
tampoco condenó los hechos ahora
cristóbal cuáles eran los argumentos de
los abogados de donantes y cuánto tiempo
se tomarán para exponer su defensa
si tendrán también 16 horas pero según
según ellos mismos van a tratar de ser
lo más preciso es posible de hecho se
dice que pueden demorarse solamente tres
horas en defender la posición de don
otro ante el argumento será muy claro
dicen y van a argumentar que donald
trump las palabras que él mencionó
cuando llamaba a fraude cuando llamada
desconocer los resultados cuando llamaba
a parar el conteo y cuando llamó el
propio 6 de enero a pelear como en el
infierno invitó a sus simpatizantes al
capitolio lo tenían no tienen nada que
ver con los actos de violencia así que
ese será el argumento que las palabras
de trump no citaron la violencia y de
hecho está diciendo uno los abogados que
siempre está muy molesto muy dolido con
que estén tratando de vincularlo con la
violencia ocurrida ese día que estaba de
gracias por información feliz resto de
noche